héloïse de voter speed aujourd'hui
retrouvent pour faire la suite de
respect à celui ci tyree j'ai pas de jeu
de mots je m'en bats les couilles c'est
parti voilà boss le médaille d'or bien
sûr pas se mentir je suis très très
chaud en pointe là j'ai bien mangé
ouais ouais bah plus de pics te plaît un
plaisir un vrai plaisir tahiri je t'aime
et merde à il faut casser des briques au
dessus pour passer ça qui se passe c'est
super dur break mais pourrait aider fois
des foyers des bugs non métalliques dont
je vous ai fait des bugs je veux
retourner à gauche c'est par ce récit
mobile en l'air et c'est aussi tu
m'explique j'ai compris j'ai comme moi
je voudrais intégrer ces personnes
regardaient rien à regarder celui de
péter le bloc en eau et faire un saut
anticipé en fait c'est une technique
tout connu un dans le jura jean voilà
elle avoue mais de quoi vous me dites
squeeze tyrese on jetterait mon genou
j'ai trouvé allez on y va en perdre
patent and times of harvey fasquel
shittu nombreux amendements demandant
aux plats ça passe nickel au staff et
m'avoir dit donc on voit que j'ai payée
ce que j'aurais pas vu ce petit cube de
merde
le dation pop était là aussi qu'il faut
être l'autre côté directement et bal
trap butin et mme hachem d'entrée de jeu
ça y est je suis déjà dans le même état
psychologique au bout d'une heure de jeu
la dernière fois en tout cas j'adore la
musique de ce nouvel là j'avoue taille
rita des très bon goût sur ce coup alors
attention est ce que ça c'est au moins
ça fixé et ben voila voila pourquoi j'y
arrive pas alors ce n'est pas le défaut
par les commerces mais elle est tout
doux on est pas à l'abri d'un petit
boîtier tout bas on se souvient à l'air
fois on a bloqué dessus et malo s'est
passé et on va avancer comme ça tout le
long parce que j'adore faire des vidéos
de merde
ok on est passé ensuite c'est quoi le
piège productif c'est mignon c'est
mignon ces innocents j'adore va te faire
à l'état les cantonner au matin mois est
excellent jeu vidéo ou allah je mérite
de mourir cette blague c'est vrai ça non
mais là c'est vrai quoi si on est bien
alors on en est là on se souvient du
petit cube d'enculés nous a tués dans ce
raid yeux bat bien sur ce front sud est
c'est quoi ça ça c'est un item à une
mort sanaa plus souvent sincère j'admire
ce talentueux à pour me péter les coudes
voile la plage des jugements à les
couches du bomb a et continue mon bas
les couilles ça va marcher
c'était une fake h mondiale fait québec
- le mec il en élargit l'os qu'on rompe
les codes les plus importants du jeu
vidéo d'aphatie fait un check polt mon
pote et pour ça eh ben je mettrai pas
liens de la description que tu vas faire
toi ça sexy ce qui se passe là l'écran
si moi je trouve ça [ __ ] de sexy mon
gars je suis plus excité que quand je
regarde transformers - les robots ça
m'excite le clat surtout pas prendre le
reste surtout pas prendre la hache
matthew webb allez allez on repense à la
joue ce soir on se dit que c'est quand
même bien plus dur que ce petit jeu de
mer vont jouer l'un 1 1 j'ai halluciné
ou pas et celui-ci procède à je meurs
vraiment 5 sur une agence celui-là 1
c'est vrai comment je suis censé aller
entre eux là où je suis et l'autre côté
sans toucher lâche-t-il épique
voilà c'est parce que je joue le père à
mes mecs c'est peut-être ça en fait j'ai
de temps de passer le cap at on appris
attendez attendez attendez inspecteurs
squeeze est de retour on peut le faire
on va le faire si on regarde bien la
hache
elle est plus à droite qu'à gauche
puisque forcément le la partie coupante
prend plus de place vous avez un compris
c'est normal j'ai compris voila voila
appelez-moi le génie ok on n'a pas cessé
de trucs et maintenant vos questions et
l'art à ya peut-être une raison
c'était la pierre raison alors ici on a
quoi au du vide bien joué j'ai envie de
te tuer toute ta famille on est parlée
québec et c'est pas possible d'être un
demeuré pareil
voilà on a su rejoindre du coup ça nous
a fait énormément de bien j'ai mal aux
enfin c'était pour la rime mais mais
pourquoi je bagasse tournoi mais je sais
pas je sais pas tu es moi ok ok on est
par là on va y arriver
c'est inouï que jeanne faire et nous y
mon gars de coups je peux passer alors
je veux dire je suis tellement content
aux lâches ou moins gros dans mon gars
qu'on va terminer ce jeu là c'est la
sensation que j'aurais que je retiens
l'état
j'ai tout pour s'excuser journaux sont
sur un super jeu vidéo avec un vrai que
j'adore ça peut être tarif d'un super
copain n'hésitez pas à les distinguer
toutes ces vidéos et studio tchèque mais
j'adore vraiment ça s'écroule on avait
tout à l'heure voilà la chine
[ __ ] c'était sa voix et l'afrique
comment tu as osé commenter osé après
tant de souffrances met un blog ici
[ __ ] il est dur se saouler tu l on y
vend n'attend pas on s'en bat les
couilles
voilà et là haut ils étaient beaux au
check polt tiens tiens tiens j'ai passé
les douanes s'est pas finir non mais là
on est d'accord
donc il faut pointer ok ok ok ok va
avoir un deuxième tout à epic des
hausses assez la france sur ces points
de sabre ou pas est un piège c'est sûr
voilà autant de proue makes the head
shot imma be
ouais on est bien passé là ok dea
d'entrée de jeu sa part sur du rouge pas
de problème l'avion des verts l'a rendue
avec difficulté extrêmement élevé dans
la petite équipe donc tu les payes
comment je passe un mec assez attend je
pense avoir donné faut fêter ça un
plaisir ça va le faire ça va le faire on
y croit les happy day c'est qu'apple
chansons pour nous peut paraître un peu
plus de lui alors la mecque ne fais pas
le con fais pas le con j'avais tout doux
la technique du tout d'où ça va passer
pas ici à bien cette mission avec la
trompette peut pas très cool mogale un
regard un peu de calme hein je me
chauffe alors comment s'appelle ce micro
à mon petit con c'est pareil c'est pas
par ici
à part la fin c'était tout droit c'était
tout droit mais je suis con mais je suis
débile au pot c'est bon c'est la fin tu
es mort mais mec t'es sérieux j'ai envie
de chialer live avec nos zones les gens
mais je vais me tuer indices cherche au
pic bleus y sont les pics blog tu
m'expliquer où sont les biclous pas
exactement c'est sale [ __ ] bleus
ils m'ont tué les pics bleus afs et par
en dessous là
cherche au pic bleus mais kiev mais
c'est quoi ça rien puis blu ray arrière
champlain de l'échelle mur y'a quoi et
rien à part une bourse et j'ai parlé
trop fait ok là on peut passer la pire
échec d'europe
ok comme ça d'accord il y en a combien
mec
les mecs monop le lie au fleuret c'est
mille fois
franchement tu hérites à 30 minutes de
gameplay mais mon qg quoi parisse plus
pendant un an avec ce jeu mon gars c'est
beau c'est beau non
non allez l'âge et mabinda je la mette
en insv l'état elle y fait pas le compte
j'aurais pas la conscience tranquille
chez papy joue à fond c'est fini
qu'est-ce que mika vient faire ici
qu'est ce que mes gars faut maintenant
non non non non je te plaît non non
vraiment déjà sur michael ganne rimer
avec mickey en face ses appuis du
mauvais pour en finir dennis k o
j'ai jamais battu mickey aussi
facilement sur jeux vidéo j'ai jamais
battu oui car tout court sur jeux vidéo
c'est génial c'est une avenue course et
finir vous avez gagné les compenser
c'est moi c'est moi c'est tout un geste
ordinaire d'un muffin à moitié du bon
hockey et ne sais pas
yaya miss pour messenger nguema tout
bientôt et voilà les jo c'est déjà la
fin de cette vidéo je suis sûr c'est
super mais je pense que c'est qu'elle ne
s'était pas le mec comme d'habitude
tarja je retire tout ce que j'ai pu dire
sur toi tu n'as même pas tactique et
général traoré ton jeu juste très très
bien c'est pour ça que j'ai rage et que
maintenant qu les faits tout vous dire
haletant s'est pas trompé de cible de
leur équipe ont nommé clermont ferrand
clermont ferrand ne pas casser c'est à
la source des prochaines deux vertèbres
regarder partout bien jobs pis
[ __ ] kadhafi tant j'étais tellement
content quand il fera cesser d'agir
on